投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,現在是臺北時間2026年9月23號禮拜三,早上8點32分。
大家早安,我是劉廷浩,每一場開盤前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞知識變化。
我們看到原油價格已經連續五天下滑了,
肺瓣也連續六天上漲了,
昨天納斯達克指數又再度創下歷史新高,
已經連續兩天了。
市場一方面去消化川普對於美伊談判這一次的最新說法
一方面也在等待川普跟習近平即將要開始會面了
那雙方針對AI針對伊朗戰事
針對關稅稀土供應
我們都很清楚知道美方現在是有所求的
如果中方能夠配合釋出一點利多新聞
那對於其中選舉肯定有拉抬作用
重點是股票市場
FOMO情緒似乎有一點再度復燃的味道
所以納斯達克指數週圍是上漲0.8%
收盤和盤中其實都是創下了歷史高點
正式突破了6月初的前高
科技股在夏季的賣壓當中其實是比較大的
這一波除了原油價格回落
沒在價格反彈以外
主要就是Meta所推出的MUSE AI
模型迅速登上了蘋果應用程式免費下載的榜首
不過臺灣還沒把下載
所以稍晚我再來使用一下
來看一下到底很多人說
使用起來其實跟豆包差不多
那到底是否能夠順應著本輪趨勢
來帶動美國的AI巨頭
科技股向上攻呢
值得留意
至少昨天費辦漲幅也不錯
Cendex漲了6.8%
希傑漲了4.8%
威騰漲了3.7%
所以其實是兩邊指數都在往上漲
那納斯達克指數由於
因為今年上半年盤整算久了
現在是率先破高
那這一波的創高啊
既有總體環境的改善
也有在個體當中在AI持續模型的推出
可是這就形成了進一步的formal心態
為什麼
因為我們都清楚知道
這一波的創高根本就沒什麼人在追
心理情緒相對於今年五六月份
比較起來是比較明顯的
現在很多人反而是在科技股創高的過程當中
開始要重新回過頭去尋找相對低基期的
可是如果從四大指數來看的話
本來相對高基期的現在也不夠低
本來相對低基期的
現在其實也不是特別便宜
這就是尷尬的進步
所以我們才講說
乖離如果真的出現了回調
基期真的已經偏低了
本益比快速下滑
也許就到達買點了
那現在從技術角度來看
也許價位就沒那麼吸引人了
不過從本益比角度來看
其實也沒有變高多少
這是我們一貫的立場
所以取決於你是用本益比投資法
還是你要針對
做乖離從情緒角度來做投資
有時候是所有指標剛好同時到位
像今年三四月份
今年七月份都是如此
那有些只有部分指標到位
我們以道瓊指數來看
昨天下跌185.0.36%
收在1863點
費半已經是本輪下壓摔得最重的
但它打到半年線也開始往上
尤其今年在七月份以後的股價下殺
它也不是殺得特別猛
所以其實位階也不算特別低
標普小跌0.06點
幾乎是持平
昨天報在7764點
那基本上納指的走高
也讓標普隨時可能創下歷史新高
納指就是昨天上漲122點
來到27244點
直接創高了
費半的部分
你不要看它位積
好像這一波跌得比較重
可是下方買盤底部
已經完全出現了
這一波也即將要挑戰
在8月份的前高
看看能否順勢突破
昨天上漲256點
2.06%
收在12689點
其實四大線型
現在看起來都還蠻漂亮的
從部分指標股
就是上一輪受傷過重的幾隻記憶體股來做追蹤
美光的部分最近股價來到1096塊
明顯突破了之前1000到1030塊的盤整壓力區
這一波是當時的重要套牢區下方的買盤開始做支撐
所以現在成功站穩以後就代表著
它至少已經把整個8月份以來的跌幅
陸續的開始進行收復了
所以從6月底高一點當時回檔來看的話
現在要突破前高
其實也沒有想象中難
因為量價圖主要就是集中在
今年的7到8月份
雖然距離歷史新高有一小段距離
可是當時也沒什麼人被套牢
所以其實要順勢拉高
也沒那麼困難
這跟臺灣的部分
像被動元件或者記憶體股
那種量價組就不太一樣
美光是已經站穩了
就是上方其實是沒有什麼太大賣壓的
再看一下SANDEX
閃迪的部分
股價來到1873塊
這也突破了過去一個多月
1,750到1,800美元的壓力區
所以從數據上來做觀察
現在已經剛剛好正式突破前波的密集套牢區了
上方其實也沒有什麼太大的壓力
這跟臺灣的很多全職股非常像
就是其實臺積電零發科上方都沒有任何壓力
那就看要不要拉的問題
只是由於全職過大
也許要做它
所需要的資金必須是國際股市外資流動性的全面回升
才能夠有效推成
不過從美國部分的指標股來看
即便當時摔很重的記憶提國
現在看起來都已經站穩了
再看一下Meta
Meta是推波助瀾
讓納斯達克指數創高的重要關鍵
昨天是小跌0.6%
不過過去一週它已經漲了11%
這是25年4月份以來的
最佳的單週表現
你看本來今年還是一個
很標準的下行通道
從2026年以來
你有沒有發現
Meta幾乎就是頭頭低
每一次的頭都比上一次還要來得低
然後就從去年10月份AI湧動機之後
它就一路進入到下行通道
這就完蛋了
結果兩週的行情瞬間就站回去了
今年又回到正報酬了
所以我們從這樣的一個角度來做思考
會發現市場仍然在尋找
不管是轉機轉型
或者說原本落後
股價未接低的股票來進行輪動
Meta這一次在2030年之前
也宣佈要投入6000億美元來建設AI建設
那祖克伯現在面對的問題
除了模型能不能進一步的進化
因為MUSE AI
它算是過去在Lama模型之後
很長一段時間沒有推出好模型之後的一步
一大步
那這麼龐大的資料中心
晶片和電力要到哪裡去找錢
還要說服地方居民接受
現在他找來新的新總裁
叫做麥考密夫
他是副董事長
接下來會共同領導Meta
而他也曾經作為高盛的合夥人
也是以前川普政府的副國安顧問
某種程度而言
祖克普把更多的時間留給工程師
和AI模型來做研發
讓他專門去處理資金
政府法律和公共的對外關係
因為他很清楚知道
AI能不能建的城
跟地方跟中央級都有密切的相關
現在AI已經從單純的模型戰
擴張到生態戰
擴張到政治戰
這就是Meta目前所採取的態勢
看看有沒有機會能夠扳回一城
事實上這一波力度應該是衝擊蠻大的
要不然亞馬遜就沒有必要封鎖MetaMuse
我們看這一次亞馬遜
把Meta的AI購物代理Muse直接給禁了
表面上他說當然是因為安全和授權問題
亞馬遜的看法是
Muse在沒有事先取得同意的情況底下
就進入到亞馬遜的網站
幫助使用者來瀏覽商品
操作賬號甚至協助賬號
而且沒有充分表示自己是AI代理人
那對於亞馬遜來說
有一個第三方的AI可以每天來我的網站來做操作
賬號安全 資料存取 交易責任都會變得非常複雜
雖然把你給禁了
那Meta當然很不爽
強調MUSE不會因為看到使用者的密碼或者付款資料
相關的憑證就會因此而被盜用走
而且這些都是有安全機制保存的
所以雙方的爭議並不是說AI到底安不安全
沒有人會說自己的AI是不安全的
是說第三方的AI到底有沒有權利
像真人一樣去使用其他公司的網站
比如說以後我AI化之後
基本上有時候我在影片上講話
可能大家也分不出來
到底是不是本人了
那我就可以交代
AI今天要講的幾個主軸
那你要記得自己開直播
自己開OBS
然後自己不能打開相機
也不需要打開了
你就這樣子直接來做露出
那有時候他幫助我
到YouTube後臺來做直播
是一個代理性AI
YouTube本身可以接受嗎
這的確是一個好的問題
但是我相信更深一層
當然是商業利益的問題
如果消費者未來只要告訴MUSE
幫我找一臺最適合我的掃地機器人
MUSE他就自己做比價了
挑選商品甚至完成購物
那消費者根本就不需要
親自逛亞馬遜
就好像我們使用LINE
使用WhatsApp
使用一些通訊軟體
那有時候我們想要知道
去年我跟一個女孩子的聊天記錄
我們當時聊了什麼
好像有點曖昧
對不對
那正常來講我們要打開
開上一個字一個字去看
懷念當時的美好
現在我只要告訴我的代理型AI
幫我到我的通訊錄裡頭去挑選
我可能有曖昧
可能有示好的言論
幫我整理我當時講了什麼
心態大概是怎麼樣
我就完全不需要使用它了
那少使用這個軟體
本身都會讓軟體業形成重大衝擊
這個是今年年初
當時SaaS末日
軟體末日的巨大衝擊
所以這場衝突比較值得觀察的是
下一代網路的入口
到底掌握在誰的手上
過去消費者想要買東西
你一定要打開亞馬遜
淘寶
Google
蝦皮
未來可能直接對AI說幫我買
他自己幫你比價
自己幫你交易
掌握的消費者
真正掌握他的人
可能就不是電商平臺了
因為最值錢的就是資料
最值錢的就是背後的後臺數據
如果最後變成AI助理的公司
掌握了這項數據
壓力就很大了
所以商方的交戰已經開始了
但也說明著
AI的潛力其實還是非常大
至少從存量競爭角度來看
它會把一筆人的生意給明顯的搶走
當然這次我們觀察到
現在市場上在FOMO情緒底下
持續推升的效果
可是從悲觀論者來看
你有沒有發現這一波的上漲
其實就是沒這麼樂觀
甚至有點悲觀
這的確是真的
因為目前所出入的報告
也並不是贊同股價就一路的向上
認為反而有繼續回調的空間
我們再抓看看有沒有機會
為什麼這樣講呢
就是因為市場現在就是FOMO
我們以摩根士坦利的首席分析師
麥克威爾森
這不是那個麥克威爾森
應該是那個麥克威爾森
對應該是
他以前是在摩根士坦利
好像也是
重點是威爾森
因為過去他一直以來都看空
我記得他有一次變看多
現在他又認為美國股市
要開始跌一層了
美股表面上距離歷史高點2%
他的態度是
美股內部是明顯分化的
羅素3000指數成分股當中
有超過40%
自6月以來已經下跌超過兩成
那標普500預估本盈比也降到19倍
所以硬要講整個大盤的確沒有這麼貴
可是威爾森認為
現在在部分個股當中
如果你去投資
它可能保持在一個標準的下行通道
所以其實股市是虛胖的
這是他目前的態度
這是FOMO心態的一環
那第二個角度
是市場上認為
目前散戶資金的買盤
並沒有想象中還要來得劇烈
如果沒有揮達的話
美股的個股資金甚至已經轉為淨賣處
它的概念就是
就是主要就是靠這些大型股票
目前在成
過去一個月
個股和整體上市證券的散戶
淨買入動能都在下滑
過去也從什麼都買的追漲模式
指向少數有題材的股票來做集中
我們舉一個比較直觀的變化
這個是半導體市場SOXX
成分股散戶的現金買盤
之前曾經一度大幅飆升
可是最近流入量開始快速的遞減
所以就算要上漲
你也不用擔心像五六月份上漲這麼快了
這是目前比較悲觀者所給予的論調
那更值得觀察的事情是
現在整個輝達的資金
如果把它扣除的話
那整體美國股市的淨資金
已經算是淨流出了
說明如果沒有幾支大型全資股的買盤
其實美國股市的總體買超幅度
並不是如同想象中的強烈
所以你只要沒有買到部分全資股
就開始有落後大盤的可能性
這是另外一層的壓力
那這些我個人認為
那都算是FOMO心態的加成
就是因為你覺得漲了
感覺沒買到
不行
早一點利空
等它下來我再結
我覺得大家的心態反而是這樣子
所以這些訊息真的是一個大利空
我們過去講過
只要沒有迎來泡沫破滅的前兆
也就是供給過剩
AI算力過剩
什麼殖利率的問題
油價的問題
美中貿易戰的問題
市場估值建制延後的問題
那個都是估值回調
那個都是中期回調
那個都不是泡沫破滅
這是我給予市場的態度
給投資朋友做一些思考
好那輝達逼近了
關鍵壓力缺口之後
杯柄形態目前
大概也逐步接近完成了
所以雖然我們觀察到
輝達股價也算盤整了一陣子
從今年3月4月5月
就這樣在高位盤旋
不過杯柄形態
其實看起來還不錯
因為它也算是
突破了大部分的量價區
那如果能夠順勢站上
那輝達能夠創高
對於整個大盤的動力
肯定影響來得更大
事實上我們知道
到輝達在過去幾個月
正在逐步變成
AI產業的中央銀行
公司市值現在5.4兆
甚至市場預估
2029年的營收
可以達到1兆美元
那更值得注意的事情就是
現在三年過去
輝達已經投入
超過700億美元
來投資這些新創
也對客戶提供
大概有3000億美元的
各類的融資支持
所以你要把它
慢慢的當成一家控股公司
科技業的不客項
尤其是針對那些新創企業
這一套模式
在AI需求高速成長的時候非常有效
它的背後代價就是風險會快速累堆
回答目前的潛在客戶的擔保
和採購的承諾大概是3000億美元
另外有250億美元
是用於未來的股權融資
以及330億美元的直接債務
那摩根士戰利的預估是
如果擔保陸續生效
回答的廣義債務
明年初從530億到後年
應該是到2000億
那這有兩個前提
一個就是AI算力需求還會成長
它還是會繼續買你的貨
而且舊晶片要仍然維持高產值
目前H100的長約租金
每個小時大概是2.8美元
只比2023年剛推出時低一層
說明就算現在是舊機款
其實也是價格很緊的
價格也是很貴的
如果未來資料中心大量完工
市場會擔心
那算力價格晶片產值開始下跌
會不會影響到輝達的銷售量
這是市場最擔心的
但是輝達已經提前做了
如果銷售量下跌
AI最後還是爆發了
第一個就結文字悖論
需求最後還是會成長
過去我們講過
那個銀行員悖論
1970年第一臺ATM誕生
所有人都覺得完了死了
銀行也要正式搜索
大財源開始了
想不到銀行分點更多了
為什麼
可以解放能力
一個銀行不需要
再這麼多貴人收取款了
你可以大量的分散到全美各地
所以這叫做
有時候一個新技術的突破
它不代表需求消失
而是需求更多的爆發
那揮達在做什麼呢
第一對賭需求會繼續爆發
第二那假設我當時也不是硬體當中
唯一百分之百龍頭市佔還能夠擴張
那我也可以藉由我的投資版圖
來扶植這些企業持續擴張
那這些企業我現在只投20億
30億像CoreWeb
像Seeking Machine Lab
我投20 30億
未來他們有可能成為下一個揮達
也許我就靠揮達控股公司的方式
成為科技業的博客項
這個就是揮達
目前所給予的態度
當然它背後最大的挑戰是什麼
就是雖然輝達本身財報
還有現在的CDS價格
沒有什麼太大變化
畢竟它是賣產值的
可是它的客戶
一個接著一個壓力越來越大
我們舉幾個角度來做思考
一個是昨天我們提到的軟銀
軟銀現在因為好賭OpenAI
最近又發行了
110億美元的垃圾債
那就代表著
接下來有進一步的
還債壓力出現
如果OpenAI不上市
它壓力只會越來越大
其中100億美元分成三種期限的美元債
還有10億歐元分成兩種期限的歐元債
主要就是因應下一輪OpenAI投資
和一般企業的用途
軟銀整體對OpenAI承諾的投資
已經650億了
是最大的投資者
現在已經逐漸變成用自己的資產負債表
在替AI擴張融資
就是我們都以為是OpenAI要拼命借錢
沒有
是軟銀已經成為OpenAI最大的支柱
所以軟銀就想辦法去借更多的錢給OpenAI
已經綁成這樣了
它造成的直接效果是什麼呢
就是目前軟銀的CDS價格
五年期又再度創下
今年以來新高了
基本上又開始挑戰
當時2024年中旬左右的水準
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
軟銀到2031年的到期美元債
五年期
它一月份大概是6.7%左右發行
五年
然後直立率給你6.7
9月這個禮拜開多少
它新發行的100億美元債券
開8.2
軟銀開8.2%的殖利率
信用違約交換成本CDS
也來到三年來的高點
說明它開得很高
但是所有人都覺得
它違約的幾率肯定是最高的
這就形成很有趣的跡象
這是軟銀史上
應該是本世紀以來
開出最漂亮的殖利率
它為了要籌錢給OpenAI
它願意發8.6%的殖利率
五年期
這個就說明著
要麼它非常看好OpenAI
要麼它真的借不到錢了
所以只好開出非常亮麗的殖利率表現
當然背後跟OpenAI有關的甲骨
我們昨天也提過了
包括總體債務的成長
24年大概800億
後來總負債一路的攀升
到26年第四季
已經拿到1560億了
持續規模的上升
這件事情都讓大家意識到
有時候我們覺得AI時代最危險的
可能是企業太安逸
你只是想要守住自己的護城河
你要靠既有的本業賺錢
你又不願意砸錢追逐新技術
然後最後就跟以前那些
錯過科技浪潮的公司一樣被淘汰
但現在科技業反而出現另外一種焦慮
那怕的不是花太多
又怕花的不夠
又不是擴張太快
但是又覺得別人比你更快
資料中心要蓋
GPU要搶
你只要慢一步
好像整個AI時代又跟你沒有關係
所以你放到AI時代
企業當然可能會因為不努力被淘汰
但你說太努力投資過頭
市場也會給你評價的
你殖利率8.6還借不到錢
那可能死得更快
這就是我們觀察到的十字跡象
那句話怎麼講的
花天酒地
平凡性交
並不會短命
但是你上班加班
熬夜應酬
更容易短命
可以理解嗎
就你每天享樂的花天酒地的
那不一定會早死
每天熬夜加班的通常都很早死
所以現在就是你要取決於
那你到底是瘋狂的支出
瘋狂的擴張自己的AI投資
還是你就好好做自己的本業
沒有兩種極端
你都在中間找平衡
你投資過頭
市場也會教訓你
軟銀就是很明顯的
這個財務狀況弄成這樣
那幾乎跟熱市
再也沒什麼區別了
但是你說
如果現在就好好做自己的本業
那你績效就跟波克夏一樣
漲幅不會太多
過去我們講過
格雷厄姆
這個矽谷的大佬
格雷厄姆曾經說過
金錢被揮霍光
往往不是因為消費
都是因為投資
我們基因裡頭
你過度消費
過度玩樂
本來就有警報器
你想要多打一天遊戲
你覺得有點愧疚感之類的
但是投資和工作不一樣
就是它沒有天然的警報器
就是你投資過頭
你可能沒感覺
你還在說服自己是對的
但其實你已經上癮了
投錢投得太誇張了
所以市場上現在是有
自我的校正迴歸機制
好那這是第一部分
也就是FOMO心態和市場的擔憂
它到底卡的點在哪裡
我們看到股市創高
然後你沒追到才會FOMO
那FOMO的理由是什麼呢
一個是市場的量體過於集中
有部分個股
漲幅並沒有想象中來得多
沒有買到重要機制
很容易現在跑出給大盤
第二種角度
其實就來自於
市場雖然知道AI資本支出
還會繼續擴張
AI行情還在持續
可是部分個股已經透露出
它這個遊戲不成功變成人
快要玩不下去的感覺
會讓市場上有一點擔憂
除非基期低一點
所以如果股價還在創高
我就不追了
股價摔回來
我考慮一下
但正用於這種風火心態
股價我們講說
總在半信半疑中持續成長
現在就是半信半疑
就是這些看壞的人
他也不敢保證AI一定不能成
但覺得如果他要能成
那我機器要買低一點
這個是大家的想法
好那第二部分就來自於
那川習會能否釋放出一些好消息
讓市場上能夠緩解一下市場的心理情緒
那大概分為兩個部分
第一個是美伊戰事的部分
中方是否有介入的空間
因為這次美國和伊朗
又直接打開對話大門了
川普在禮拜二紐約聯合國大會
場邊跟伊朗代表
已經開始進行三個小時的會談
那當然他形容這場會談
非常好
非常的有效
而且促使其他一系列的特使
都有相關參與
雙方近期的互動
頻率開始顯著拉昇
但是呢
他在講話的同時
談判的同時
川普又馬上在聯合國大會
警告說
如果無法達成和平協議
美國會進一步對於伊朗
採取行動
就一邊做壓制
一邊來和談
那到底最後反應如何呢
至少從原油價格來看
市場是有點信心的
那有信心有兩個原因
第一個是美伊最近又看起來正在談了
談判期間沒出什麼亂子
至少可以讓原油價格做一些獲利了結
那第二部分就是沙烏地的紅海輸油管線
最近準備要重啟了
之前被無人機空襲
有一半的產能被傷害到了
那現在其實這種東西
一顆飛彈打過去又要開始停擺兩個月了
不過至少最近是重啟了
這條管線每天運送400萬桶的原油
是沙烏地阿拉伯避開赫姆茲海峽的重要出口路線
現在就往鴻海的鹽埠港來做運送
那中東的原油供給的損失
大概每天佔錢是1200萬到1300萬桶
現在每天就470萬桶
所以其實原油衝擊仍然在持續當中
現在唯一的好處是什麼呢
是全球其他地區的產能已經慢慢的開出來
那另外一個比較大的壓力就是
原油現在產能陸續開出以後
可是全球的煉油廠
成品油的供給仍然補不上缺口
根據國際能源總署的估計
整個8月份全球成品油的產量
比前一年少了400萬桶
所以即便全球的其他原油產出更快
但是成品油並沒有因此而跟上
所以柴油尤其重要
柴油是三分之一的石油需求
從卡車運輸到農業
工業到冬季的供暖都離不開它
所以川普雖然他也沒有打包票
其中選舉前就可以結束
但是他在盡他的可能
打通赫姆茨海峽的航線
目前按照市場數據
的確有越來越多的遊輪
開始從赫姆茨海峽來運出來
不過仍然會遭受到伊朗的控制
雙方仍然有互相零星交火
這是我們觀察到的市值方向
下面有股市
大概就是四根手指頭
整理得很工整
四大利空
油價
殖利率
AI資本支出
然後再來就資金退潮
量不夠大
油價就是能源價格重新走高
現在回跌
但是9字頭也是一樣貴
第二個就殖利率
接近5%
大家開的投資等級
在殖利率也越來越高
現金成本就越來越貴
第三AI資本支出
你也不確定明年是不是又要擴張
你要從哪裡借來這些錢
最後就資金退潮
現在就少數科技股
扣掉匯達以後
的確散戶對於個股
已經屬於淨賣出
油價 殖利率 AI資本支出
還有資金退潮
所以它有點像
昨天不是看一個網友分享給我
講說那個手指頭切菜
不小心四根手指頭都切掉了
醫生還問他你感覺怎麼樣
他比個讚這樣子
有時候我們講說
你只要獲利沒有一起斷掉
這個市場就還有理由撐著
就是四根手指頭都切到了
可是你問他基本面怎麼樣
基本面就很不錯
基本面很不錯
那本益比不就下滑了嗎
所以這些都是利空
但基本面很不錯
而這就是唯一的大拇指
所以這給投資朋友做一些參考
這我的看法
當然川習會現在比較要聚焦的
就是川普和習近平在白宮會面
AI已經成為了美中競爭最為核心的一體
現在雙方基本上應該會面的可能性是很高
因為前幾天我們才看到有一些新聞
那個新聞講的就是說雙方
因為習近平當時好像是在
是前幾天吧
上禮拜還是上上禮拜
忘記了
就是出現一些身體的不適
所以有幾天是沒露面
後來是在跟穆迪會面的時候
當時好像是稍微暈倒
還是怎麼樣
不太舒服
目前沒有可靠證據
好像身體不適
我那時候看了一下畫面
穆迪還問他說
你還好嗎
後來我看好像應該還好
我在想可能是心悸
因為要調時差
那現在要到美國
可能喝咖啡會心悸
心臟痛一下
所以我覺得應該
今天晚上應該就會會面了
突然想到史迪奇
為什麼不能喝咖啡
因為它是心機寶貝
好沒事
那雙方現在要討論的焦點
就來自於現在的稀土磁鐵霸權
因為全球現在仍然有94%的產能
在中國手上
美國扎欽還是很難追上
所以這一次的首要談判目標
是確保上一次的談判成果
在稀土層面有更多的管制鬆綁
其實中方對美方已經幾乎是全面鬆綁了
只是差別在於還是採取許可制
那美方當然希望
你可以把許可制給取消
並且在中東問題上予以配合
瓦解這條問題
那中方是不是有必要
一定要讓伊朗戰事持續僵持呢
可能在國策上是有利的
可是在目前的能源供給上
大家綁在的是同一條路線上
當然不希望能源價格水漲船高
所以雙方到底有沒有合作條件
我們後續再來做一些觀察
那另外一個就是
美中之間的AI公司談判
之所以我們講說
這是最好能夠洽談的議題
我們明明都知道
美中雙方還在競爭
怎麼可能AI會有共同的自理規範
我反倒認為這是最有機會的
原因在於雙方都對於恐怖主義
都對於分離勢力
或者一些這種恐怖主義可能形成的傷害
知道AI可能會推波助瀾
所以雙方如果在一定的共同準則底下
阻止那種AI產生的外溢性效果
可能會有恐怖攻擊
或者會對於青少年所造成的傷害
建立一套共同準則
現在目前反而看出來
是雙方最有可能傳出好消息的地方
我們之前就有看到
那個葉門的青年運動
他就用那個Anthropic
每天都在查說要如何做炸彈
然後一步一步的去研究
最後被Anthropic給發現了
直接通報五角大廈
五角大廈馬上就採取行動了
所以我們都清楚知道
這有兩個啟示
第一個就是
AI的威力和他的知識體系
是足以造成一些市場上的重大副作用的
尤其被危險的人給使用
第二個就是
就是沒事不要使用AI問一些很奇怪的問題
問為什麼分叉
那entropy就知道你分叉了
所以這壓力很大
很隱私的問題就不要看了
這本來就是使用AI
我們以前都會覺得說
你有什麼問題就照問
沒什麼問題
可是當你問的問題越來越細以後
你要了解你問的所有問題
照理講美國政府應該都知道
所以差別在於你問什麼樣的一個問題
你有時候就要用別人的名字問
誰誰誰問的
不要當成自己
昨天我才講說
因為現在其實使用任何的AI
它都會留下使用記錄
即便你把最後的對話框給刪掉
人家也知道
所以任何我們講的
之前中方也有傳出一些訊息
用Anthropy來詢問一些具體的間諜行動
一樣被Anthropy給看到了
所以我才覺得特別有趣
任何的網絡其實都會留下使用記錄
你在查之前一定要三思
那昨天我才看到有一段對話
人家問說
為什麼人類的情侶
可以互看生殖器
但是卻不能夠互看手機
後來想通了
如果生殖器會留下使用記錄
那你以後也不能看了
所以這就是
或者手機有別人的生殖器
不重要
重點就是
因為裡頭就有資訊
有記錄下去以後
它當然對於AI的使用性
會造成極大衝擊
雙方如果能夠建立
共同的AI準則
去以防
人家問炸彈怎麼製作
我放在地鐵站
是不是比另外一個地鐵站放得更好
能夠自動的偵測
通常在第一秒鐘
他就不讓你問了
但是如果你繼續往下問
那麼就可能提交當地的警察局
這是我認為阻止犯罪最好的做法了
也給投資朋友做些思考了
好那因為時間因素
再往下聊時間不太夠
但我們主要跟投資朋友稍微分享
現在市場上幾大焦點
第一個就是FOMO回來了
那納指的創高
資金其實只敢追比較強的AI
那當然現在看到的股價創高
由於自己又沒有上車
這種FOMO心態才會持續的加強
所以利空才會頻繁
這就是FOMO心態的特點
股價創高卻滿滿是利空
大家總會擔憂這擔憂那
這是很標準的
行情總在半星半夜中成長
第二
油價我認為還是本輪FOMO
能不能持續延遲的總開關
因為這一波FOMO心態
跟油價的回跌是有密切聯動的
開關在川普手上
現在沙爾第阿卜的東西油項管線
已經開始逐步的恢復
原油供應也改善
臺股也創高了
納斯達克指數也創高了
可是雙方原油價格跌到90頭
有沒有再往下跌的空間呢
以前的連結是油價到通膨
到連準會到美債殖利率
到科技估值
那現在期中選舉
壓油價已經是很必要的任務了
那還能夠壓多低呢
所以第二個事情要取決於川普
那第三全部都要收斂到川習會
因為川普現在同時要處理中國問題
儘量傳出好消息
一兩問題
還有期中選舉
那習近平今天已經抵達華府了
正式會談
明天就會舉行
今天晚上應該會先見面
看看有沒有新聞畫面釋出
議題會包含
關稅 稀土 AI 農產品
還有中國和伊朗的關係
對於川普來說
最重要的是
當然是希望能夠換到
農產品的採購
進一步的擴增
然後還有在部分稀土供應商
能夠順勢的打通
如果可以的話
就回過頭來處理國內政治
或者在通膨上
能夠做有效的壓制
所以如果把整場直播
我們把它串起來
大概就是市場現在很風模
那這個風模呢
也不是隻有AI基本面撐起來的
油價跌
殖利率才有機會松
科技股才敢漲
那油價背後是每一談判
每一談判又佔著中國
最後呢
全部回到川普最現實的問題
距離其中選舉越近
他能不能把油價壓下來
他能不能跟習近平談出好成果
同時又讓美國股市
繼續維持在風險的高偏好
這給投資朋友做些思考了
By the way
明天因為早上有點事情
我們會改採錄播的形式
來跟投資朋友見面
我們今天主要是跟投資朋友分享
在川習會之前
市場的種種訊息
來拼湊出一個畫面
稍晚過幾天
我們再來看待一下
這一次美中關稅戰
是否有機會能夠緩和一下局勢
目前看起來
在其中選舉之前
也只有緩和的可能
看起來沒有任何支線
可能引爆新一輪的關稅戰
畢竟現在要想辦法的是救民調
而並不是採取新一輪
有利於美國經濟利益的行動
為什麼
因為都有政策的時間線
現在就選群
應該是川普當務之急
也給投資朋友做一些思考
臺股上漲402點
刷了48202點
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上八點半
早晨財經速解讀再相見
祝各位投資朋友看盤順利
操盤愉快